[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video were going to be discussing
one of our favorite female lead
characters mynique Granger in the years
that Hermione Granger spent at Hogwarts
she was widely considered to be the
brightest Witch of her age time and time
again she displayed lateral thinking
quickly adjusting to her circumstances
or environments and overcoming all sorts
of obstacles not only that but she has
an inquisitive and practical mind which
allows her to constantly challenge the
status quo frequently introducing new
approaches to conventional methods of
spell conjuring or potion making before
she even began attending the school
Hermione was reading up on spells and
practicing them and that was most
impressive about my knees magical Talent
she's the only witch in her family
that's right
Hermione's parents had muggle dentists
so if you like me then at some point or
another you've probably asked yourself
where and when did Hermione find out
that she was magical that she was a
witch was she knowingly casting spells
before Hogwarts ever took notice of her
or did she not exhibit any sign of
magical ability until her Hogwarts
letter came in this video were going to
take a closer look we knew that Harry
grew up in similar circumstances
entirely unknowing of his magical
background and raised by muggles Harry
had his fair share of unusual accidents
forever finding out that he was a wizard
things like growing his hair back
quickly after unwanted haircuts and
talking to snakes these aren't normal
occurrences for maka boy so did Hermione
have similar things happen to her in the
philosopher's stone hermione explains
that she found out that she was a witch
when she received a Hogwarts letter and
that it was quite a surprise nobody of
my family's magic at all it was ever
such a surprise when I got my letter but
I was ever so pleased of course I mean
it's the very best school for witchcraft
there is I've heard I've learned all of
our set books off by heart of course I
just hope it will be enough I'm Hermione
Granger by the way who are you
but finding out that you are officially
a witch is not the same as understanding
that you're different that your magical
did have my knee know that she was
different before her letter came when we
first meet her she brags that she has
tried some simple spells at home before
starting her first year at Hogwarts did
she do that in the time between getting
a letter and getting on the train if we
take a look at how the quill
acceptance works we can derive that she
must have performed some kind of magic
at some point before attending the
school in a small locked tower never
visited by any student at Hogwarts sits
an ancient book that has not been
touched by human hands since the four
founders placed it there on completion
of the castle beside the book which is
bound in peeling black dragon height
stands a small silver ink pot and from
this protrusion long faded quill these
are the quill of acceptance and the book
of admittance and they constitute the
only process by which students are
selected for Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry the book and
quill were put in place by the founders
of Hogwarts to aid with and automate the
Hogwarts selection process one of the
main parameters between place of
accepting students is as follows at the
precise moment that a child first
exhibits signs of magic the quill which
is believed to have been taken from an
augury floats up out of its ink pot an
attempt to inscribe the name of that
child on the pages of the book this
means that as soon as the child shows
any form of magic it is immediately set
in writing that they are a magical being
no child would be able to perform magic
undetected without this magical book and
quill taking note of it
so if Hermione received a letter but it
means that she must have performed some
magic
additionally in an interview with JK
Rowling Rowling reveals that her parents
have always been a bit amused by her
behavior you see so much of Ron's family
so I thought that I would keep
Hermione's family
by contrast quite ordinary they are
dentists as you know they are a bit
bemused by the odd daughter but quite
proud of her all the same whether this
quote indicates that they are bemused by
her general demeanor or her magical
abilities is up for us to decide so did
she know that she was magical
one of Hermione's defining
characteristics is her intelligence and
I am of the impression that she knew
that she was quite different maybe she
didn't know that she was a witch but I'm
certain she knew she was magical and was
more cognizant of her capabilities than
young Harry I bet she was on the quill
of acceptances list for many many years
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content plead him to like the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]